hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from the 2008 in
European club Cup it's a game a lot of
you have requested me to show and also I
received some very nice footage from
Nikki Riga so it would be a shame not to
show a such a lovely game it's a game
between Bingley Hren and Peter Svidler
and prior to this game I think is on a
90 game unbeaten streak so this is if he
manages to survive this game it will be
his 91st game that he goes without being
defeated last one was against the
onigiri last last year in September as
we've already mentioned and here we have
a score between Bingley rain and Peter
Svidler so far so far in classical games
Dingley rain beat Svidler 2 to 1 with
four draws so here a spoiler has a very
nice chance to equalize and also if you
consider rapid and exhibition games it's
a two to one with 5 draws so one rapid
game was drawn a lot of you have asked
me where do I find scores on mutual
encounters I look for it on chess chess
games calm so I'll put a link to it in
the description below if you want you
can just type any player against any
player and you will have their official
scores I don't think I mean I don't know
if the database is like fully filled but
so far I think it was a pretty good so
like well like I said I did receive some
very nice footage so here I even lowered
the volume even more so we'll see I will
get there here we have some nice footage
of the Dingley and there you have it
taking a peek at Svidler now and then
it's a it's already from the end game
but it will be a very interesting game
see every now and then he takes a peek
and also we have some very nice footage
of Svidler there you have it
someone mentions that the the lagging
during the video is because Nikki was
taking photos during the video but I
actually think it's due to my poor PC
configuration so there we have it now
let's check out this very nice game so
dink has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 and now
g6 the King's Indian is on the board and
here but tonight the c3 and the d5 we
could transpose into a groom for defense
but dink knows that Saylor is one of the
greatest groom field players that are
currently playing so he avoids that he
plays f3 here it's something called the
ante room for defense the ante group
fold system we have Knight to c6 by
Svidler and then out d5 grabbing more
space Knight to e5 and now e for so now
not not uncommon White has this very
nice pawn chain in the center but silver
has two knights already developed
we have d6 and then out comes Knight to
c3 c6 by sliver and now f4 kicking the
night even further back
Knight e to the 7 and now D as the pawn
advanced from F 3 to F 4 d4 pawn is not
summer week as well it goes back with
the knight prepares Knights to c5 to
pressure the e4 pawn from here and here
unknown game was from 2010 from the
Chess Olympiad Kramnik vs. noir aware
chronic played Bishop to e3 to wait this
night to come to c5 but dink has a
different idea he prepared Knight to h3
and now he's ready to meet a Svidler
night to c5 which was played in the game
with night 2 f2 and now guarding the e4
pawn twice with both nights so a very
funny funny situation here where the e4
pawn is attacked twice by the Knights
and also guarded twice by the Knights
there we have it Bishop to g7 by settler
developing the bishop preparing the
castle and now Bishop to e2 we have
castles by cellular Bishop to e3 and now
pawn captures on d5 C captors on d5 and
Queen to a5 now the c3 pawn is pinned
indefinitely Knight captures on e4 is a
threat
we have castles here and Bishop to d7
fiddler develops a bishop and knock
'if I've it's one of those moments where
you don't think that II five is coming
and you always have to take me five into
consideration but this is one of the
moments where it it can definitely
happen thing pushes the e5 and we have
Knights to e8 capturing doesn't really
give anything to black white was simply
now capture here he will have a very
nice pawn chain in the center and Knight
will still have to go to eight and every
brush up to d4 it will be simply a much
more a much better and much more
enjoyable position for white after e5
Knight to e8 and the knock comes Queen
to d4 a very nice centralizing move by
the Queen the Queen is the d4 is an
excellent square for the Queen and now
you you can never even capture here
because the night is now attacked twice
by the Queen and the bishop so nice to
a4 so Hitler wants to exchange some
pieces we had a nice capture Sunday for
Queen capture something for offering a
trade of Queens and now rook a to see
one thing doesn't mind here it seems
like the thing is offering the A to
point but a to pawn is it's a it's
somewhat of a poisoned pawn because if
you capture it then comes rook to e1
attacking the Queen and that free Queen
to b3 now comes the bishop to d1 again
attacking the Queen after D captures on
e5 attacking whites Queen F captures on
e5 now you have a problem you can either
play Queen to b4 or you can go Queen to
b6 but whatever you do for example even
if you go let's say Queen to b6
characters characters and now your roof
is unguarded and if you play something
like Queen to b5 then the problem is a
bunch of to a4 now you lose the bishop
on d7 when you move the Queen captures
captures okay now you don't lose the
roof but you lose the undefended bishop
here and yeah Queen to b4 it doesn't
work for obvious reasons as before is
guarded by the Queen
so after rook a to c1 of course you
cannot capture the pawn Queen to a5
sweedler avoids the trade of Queens and
he wants to trade trade down even more
pieces so K Knight to e4
a very nice centralizing move by the
knight probably didn't had this in mind
when he played this Knight to h3 and
knowing that it will come to f2 and at
sample
that it can come to e4 so Knight to h3
seems like a very nice plan in the
industry ation Bishop to b5 hoping to
exchange more pieces bushel capture
screen captures and now b3 are simply
improving the the structure of the pawns
on the Queen side and the D captures on
e5 here rook to d8 was definitely an
idea but this is the problem you don't
gain any control over the C file and
your rooks are still not connected so
instead Svidler finds a very nice plan
on how to get to denied back into the
game and also connect rooks by even
controlling the C file
he plays D captures on e5 we have F
captors on e5 and not Knight to d6 s d5
pawn is pinned you cannot capture the
night now the knight is nicely developed
in the future it can either exchange
here or come to a5 and the rooks are now
connected so rook is definitely coming
to c8 Bush of 2 F for controlling the de
5 pawn and now comes a rook a to c8 as
we've already mentioned Knight to c3 we
have Queen to a5 now with a double
attack against the c3 Knight but also as
you can see the bishop is also sort of
eyeing this knight on c3 we have Queen
to d3 here and here as fiddler plays
Knight to f5 as not this this was
definitely an idea but also an
interesting move was east 6 with the
idea that if pawn captures here that you
can capture on c3 because now both the
Queen rook and the bishop are
controlling the c3 square the problem is
after rook captures Queen capture screen
Jefferson Bishop captures black didn't
really gain all that much for example
rook to c1 attacking the bishop bishop
checks
King give one and now rook to d8
attacking the pawn but now you get a lot
of activity with this rook to c7 move
and if I will not help you as you will
not be able to win the pawn due to
Bishop to h6 now controlling all of
these very nice dark squares and now of
course rook captures is impossible due
to bank back rank issues such as such as
checkmate so after a queen to d3 knights
the five best fiddler and now you have
g4
if you remember in the previous game
Carson is
a very nice opportunity to play G for
that supercomputer line we've mentioned
but here in this game ding it does not
miss his opportunity to push g4 ok Queen
to b6 check and now King to h1 and now
comes Queen to D force wheeler finds a
way to hopefully exchange Queens here
and getting his Knights to use
Foursquare but ding of course refuses
this Queen to b4 he wants to trade
Queens but on e4 and the knight will
still have to find a nice square so okay
Queen captures Knight captures and now
Knight to d4 Roxy to be 1 attacking the
knight we have nice to e2 and the now
comes Bishop to g5 and here black has a
lot of problems here d6 is definitely
coming at some point now here as ding is
threatening to capture these seven pawn
and it's not all that clear how to
prevent it
for example if you play rook F de 8
defending a d7 pondan this d6 is a very
strong move already are threatening d7
wouldn't attack against both rooks
captures captures even if you capture
the night it will not help you d7 and
the diversion is controlling the d8
square white is white is completely
winning here on the other hand you can
also try to play Roxy to e8 but still it
will not help you if you play rook D to
see it then the rook is no longer
controlling the C file and the c3 square
was a very important retreat square for
this night so now you can simply attack
it and the knight doesn't have anywhere
to go you have to play f5 attack White's
night here and after G captures G
captures now you capture on e2 and
therefore F captures here
then you play d6 captures captures and
again it will be impossible to prevent
the d7 and the division of is guarding
the queening square here if you wanna
block it block with the Bishop Bishop to
f6 now you get Bishop to h6 attacking
the rook rook the rook to have 7 and now
rook the g1 check King has to go to h8
and now look to f2
threatening a lot of nasty ideas like
Bishop a rook captures here and Bishop
to g7 picking up the other rook so after
rook e6 blocking now you get rook to c1
a threatening rope to CH check so
Teru goes back now you have this very
nice d7 move and after captures you
simply win a piece this is only one of
the problems black faces here in in
figuring out how to defend this e 7
point eater with this record with this
rook sauce wheeler finds a different way
he decides to sort of temporarily give
up a pawn but as you'll see it will not
be temporarily
he plays f6 here and ok he characters on
f6 pawn captures and now Knight captures
to grabbing a pawn Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now Knight to c3 and
here you have this idea where of course
you can capture here but then it white
will give up a very strong bishop and
also you can see that the knight is
attacking the a to pawn here and also
the rook on d1 but here ding plays a
very strong move rook to d4 it doesn't
allow this night to go anywhere and here
we have rook C to D 8 I would a double
attack against the d5 pawn giving up the
exchange but only temporarily Bishop
captures rook captures on f1 with check
King to g2 attacking the rook rook goes
back to f7
and now comes d6 so advancing his past
pawn and here rook to d7 so this is
everything both of them calculated at
that point that fiddler decided to play
f6 and here we have Bishop to g5 as the
bishop was under attack and this is the
critical moment of the game here black
has to play King to f7 and he is still
very much in the game the a 2 point is
under attack
after you advance that king is coming to
e6 already with such an active King
black has black definitely has chances
of fighting this out to a draw even
being upon down but here a swivel played
Knight captures on a2 and Knight
captures an a2 is a move one would not
make in this position if you just had
this position and then someone told you
find the move here it's a move that ass
will most likely so when he played f6
and then he calculated all the way here
he saw that he would grab grab a pawn
back he would not be down in material
and all would be well
but feel free to pause the video here
and try to take advantage of this nights
way to move as white I'll give you a
couple of seconds to decide whether we
want to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent and game player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show here didn't play Bishop to d2
and now you immediately get the idea of
what's going on you have this famous
relationship between a bishop and the
night when the bishop and Knight are
apart two squares then the bishop is
controlling all of the squares that the
knight can jump to so the knight can go
anywhere the knight is trapped
of course the threat is now rocked to a
four and rope to a to capturing the
night so you can't really prevent this
if you try a five here what's the idea
of creating an escape square for the
knight simply Bishop captures you have
to waste a pawn here to create an escape
route for your knight but then again you
will not be equal in material and on the
other hand after this Bishop to D to
move s will go try the b5 controlling
day before square now rook to a4 is not
possible but here Dean finds a different
idea so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the next move that
is actually winning for white so for
those of you who were able to do it once
again congratulations you are an
excellent Indian player and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
b4 is the moving plate I kind of give
you a little hint because I kind of
wiggled it around a bit but you know I
never usually give you hints so I guess
it's not that terrible and now there's
really no defense against what's coming
simply rook to d3 rook to a3 and picking
up the night there's no avoiding this as
fiddle or play King to have 7 and F 2
root 2 D 3 as wheeler resigned the game
unmoved 41 when the time control was
finally reached there's there's no way
around it if you try something like a
5-pound captures and now before to
create some squares for the knight here
it doesn't work because simply a6 and
now after Knight to c3 a 7 is coming
once row captures that now d7 is coming
and there is no stopping this point from
queening well
there is but you would have to give up a
rook for example
rook captures rook captures you are down
a piece there's no way to put the pawn
because Bishop captures captures and it
is all over
so yeah very nice very nice game by by
the England and yeah probably it was a
this night capture Sunday to move
probably something sweet or calculated
while he decided to defend VI f6 but
there was no other way as you've seen
defending the e7 pone was not possible
via any of the rooks and then f6 was a
must but here you simply cannot capture
it you have to bring the King into the
game and you can still fight so an
excellent game and with this game
Dingley Orion is now on a 91 game
unbeaten streak as you know often it is
mentioned that Michael Tao holds the
world record for foreign unbeaten streak
with 95 games of being unbeaten but it
is actually Syria TV akov who holds the
record with a hundred and ten games I do
not have this confirmed and a lot of
times when people are talking about this
they say that TV akov claims that he has
this and I haven't seen it like
confirmed anywhere but if he says it I
believe it is true so dink has well four
more games the reached all the record
but he has to reach 110 games to reach
TV echos record so does the game ding
leerin vs. Peter Svidler
in the 2018 European club cop I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I'll see you soon with some
more interesting games from the this
European club cop I will see how Coulson
and manages his game with against
mamedyarov
and also we are returning to the Bobby
Fischer series of course thank you and
I'll see you soon